the labour mp don butler has accused the
metropolitan police of racial profiling
after the car she was in was stopped in
london
the former shadow equalities minister
filmed the incident in hackney
in which she said officers stopped her
friend who was driving here's just
a little bit of what happened the other
police officer asked me where i live
where i was going that's also none of
your business yeah
it's none of your do you understand that
it is none
when you're driving a car then under the
road traffic attack
then we can stop a vehicle and we can
check the driver's license
but it's none of you but it's none of
your business where i'm going where are
we
where else are you where else are you
going to drive a car other than on a
public road like i said i'm not i'm not
asking you
so can i just say something your
attitude is great
your attitude stinks and i have your
details
following the release of that video the
metropolitan police said their officers
had
incorrectly entered the registration
into a police computer
which identified the car as registered
to an address in yorkshire you heard
that reference there
the statement added once the mistake was
realized the officer sought to explain
this to the occupants then were then
allowed on their way no searches were
carried out
on any individuals apple joining us now
i'm pleased to say
the labour mp don butler ms butler
always lovely to see you thanks for
joining us on the programme this morning
um
i i want to deal with the the met
statement in just a second
but i wonder if you might respond to to
comments which i'm sure you'll have seen
cromping up on your social media just as
much as they have on mine this morning
suggesting that the the video was
flipped to make it look like you were in
the driving seat and indeed
that the driver of the car the other
person in the car was not black as
as you said but was quite i wonder if
you might just respond to that
it was quite interesting to go on to
twitter
late last night and then start seeing
all these sort of conspiracy theories
and it just made me think that the
lengths that people will go through
just to excuse you know racism away
or discrimination away or injustice
away i mean it it just shocked me
i mean why would i why would i flip my
camera i pressed record
and i was recording and i turned the
camera when i had to
record the police officer there was no
flipping of the camera
my friend is black um and
it'd be quite insulted that somebody's
saying that he's trying to
you know what is that about it you know
i was i was a passenger we got stopped
i am black he's black he drives a fairly
nice car
the police stopped us and said the car
was registered to north yorkshire
i don't understand why that is a
reason to stop somebody if they're from
north yorkshire but that was what the
police
said so um you know the police have
given their reason for the stop i think
the important thing is
is that um we work together to change
the system because the system doesn't
work
85 of black people who were stopped
are released with no further action that
means that they're using a system that
has a 15
success rate that's not a very good
success rate for a system
just in terms of what we saw on the
video that
one of the officers seemed to be
suggesting that because you were driving
through
hackney they needed to make sure that
people were there for
for proper purposes and so on what on
earth was he driving
what did you take from what he was
saying there well
this is the thing that became quite
irritating in terms of
nothing making sense everything left me
scratching my head
you know driving on a public road where
else are we going to be driving
to make sure we're in the area for the
right reason
we're driving through i wasn't actually
going to eat in hackney but there are
some nice places to eat in hackney
so none of this made sense but i think
in a way
it shows you the bias and the assumption
that happens when you see
black people uh in a car
you know driving that they're
automatically saying we need to check
that
these people are here for the right
reason that they are not
um criminals and we need to change that
we need to change that thinking and
that's going to take
a lot of effort and it needs to be done
quickly so it needs to be quite
intense and that's why i think it's
important that um
i work with the police but organizations
that have been working on this for
many years trying to change the system
that doesn't work and
over-polices black people and
criminalizes black people
and yes sometimes it's a difficult
conversation sometimes an uncomfortable
conversation
but it's a conversation that has to be
had because really this cannot be
this cannot continue and in the light of
black lives matter what we're trying to
do
is dismantle the structural racism that
takes place and mcpherson has said that
the police the met police is
institutionally racist
christopher dick doesn't like that term
that is that is not something that she
should be saying what she should be
saying is
you know i lead an organization that is
still institutionally racist after 20
years
i need to stop that i need to cut that
institutional racism out of the met
force would do whatever it takes and
that's what she should be saying
and that is what she's not saying so i
think that you know there's a lot of
work to be done but it needs to be done
intensely and it needs to be done
quickly and it gives us an opportunity
to do that i don't want to be stopped on
a sunny sunday afternoon it ruined my
sunday night it ruined my sunday
just just in terms of though this
statement then from the met
identifying you know an incorrectly uh
typed license plate into
a computer as there is the reason for
all of this
what do you make of that because
certainly it was referenced by the
police officers
who were there you know how how are you
some people will ask how are you so
certain that this was was it was an
obvious
and equally as an egregious example of
people
simply being pulled over because you
know two black people in
a nice in a nice car as you put it i
mean this happens to black people
every single day this happens to black
men every single day whether they're
walking
or driving or on a bike it happens to
them every single
day the facts are this we were driving
around
10 miles an hour because the lights were
changing we
there was no illegal activity happening
we were two black people in a car in
hackney those are the facts that
indisputable facts so the rest of it is
really up to the police what made them
think that we were suspicious
what made them punch the registration
number into the system
what made them think if we're coming
from north yorkshire there's a problem
i mean i don't know maybe there are
county lines issues
i don't know maybe there is i don't know
i'm really sorry to interrupt we've only
got about 50 seconds left i just
i just wonder what your view is this
morning
of the police officers that you
interacted with on sunday oh one of them
was fine and i said to him
you know the way you stopped is
perfectly polite my wishing is the
reason for you stop in
so you know if the reason is wrong then
there's a problem there the other two
police officers
were there to agitate and to make
trouble and i think that that's those
attitudes
need to be taken out of the police force
because it does nobody
any justice whatsoever that's terrible
ms butler as i said always good to see
you thanks very much
for joining us on the program once again
thank you